[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois fois par semaine sur ce stade de
foot de la région parisienne une
association réonnaise se retrouve autour
du ballon rond allez le même truc que
tout à
l'heure nous à monre à Paris
20e là comme tous les mercredi soir les
rayonnais qui est sur Paris on île- de
France nous donne à nous rendez-vous sur
ce stade là c'est l'ultramarine
l'association sportif
[Musique]
ultramarine comment fait frais mais
comme on voit j 18 à l'entraînement ben
nous aime football nous aime le sport
qui permett à nous de retrouver à nous
après un jouré travail ben n est
toujours présent même s'il fait 3 degr
nous est
là là dans cette équipe des réunonnais
de différentes générations mais tous
sont venus tenter l'aventure
professionnelle à Paris tout comme ces
deux jeune
gardien je suis venu faire un tour en
France voir comment c'étaitussi parce
que changer un peu la vie fatigué un peu
la Réunion ils m'ont aidé pour tout
l'appartement quand je suis arrivé ils
sont venus me
chercher fait avance à nous Gard un peu
travail pour nous garder
tro tris concours c'est les rayonn entre
en France il y a une bonne entente ils
sont là à n'importe quel moment tu peux
les appeler à minuit 1 heure du matin
ils seront là c'est pas famille mais
après quand est en France comment il
devient il un pe comm par que est loin
d'e vraie famille après football c'est
un sport d'équipe c'est la deuxè famille
un accompagnement et une solidarité
encouragé par le Conseil départemental
installé dans le 4e arrondissement de
Paris cet accompagnement consiste à déjà
une politique d'aide du département une
aide à la structure he donc en fonction
du nombre d'adhérents qu'ils ont et une
aide à l'accompagnement de individuel à
l'accompagnement et pour une aide pour
les grandes manifestations pour de
promotion un des collectifs
d'association qui se trouve en
[Musique]
région ces images montrent bien la
diversité des actions réalisées au
quotidien par les 120 associations
réionnaises de
l'Hexagone nous retrouvons des membres
actifs lors de l'inauguration de la
boutique de l'antenne de Paris fait pas
mal d'années région parisienne et le
fait deetrou déjà V
association retrouve avoir le moral et
ceteraetrouve un pe chaleur à la Réunion
on va dire tout même quoi après avir
l'antenne de Paris
sur général sur Paris il permett à nous
déjà nous en tant queassociation beso
petit besoin matériel et
ca et quoi donc c'est un travail
collectif retour sur le terrain de foot
o malgré un al qui Balit la pelouse les
joueurs donnent paquet à la base c'était
pour vraiment retrouve à nous le weekend
la semaine l'entraînement c'était
vraiment fait camarade nous les pas
football nous c'est c'est un rêve pour
nous c'est un rêve pour nousi mais en
plus c'est les gars la rion il arrivve
et ben les gars il prend contact avec
nous par téléphone par facebook bouche à
oreille ben nous ben comme nous football
N a l'ambition ben les gar bon niveau la
Réunion connait football la
Réunion vidéo Une pe vidéo déjà qu é en
Espagne le tour en Espagne en Espagne
Barcelone tour Barcelone mois de mais
après franchement pas parce que la ré
chez nous quand même JIS ça j ça ce
travail de l'ombre de toutes ces
associations est une chance pour la
diaspora
[Applaudissements]
réonnaise
une énergie positive mdine
réignon allez allez allez
allez allez allez allez
allez